je lui ai demandé ce qui se passait et
c'est là qu'elle a raconté que Lucile
n'était pas rentré
j'ai répondu que ce n'était pas grave on
allait la retrouver je pensais qu'elle
avait rencontré quelqu'un elle me répond
non non elle venait d'appeler des
copines chez qui elle devait se rendre
elle n'est jamais arrivé alors là j'ai
dit c'est différent on a un problème
c'était le 12 janvier dernier ce
matin-là la petite ville de couche time
en Autriche se réveille sur une scène de
crime
le corps sans vie d'une jeune femme
vient d'être retrouvé sur les bordelines
la rivière qui traverse la ville le
crâne fracassé par plusieurs coups
ultra-violent
la victime froidement assassinée est une
étudiante française
originaire de la région lyonnaise Lucile
claubut avait 20 ans
le jour même les plongeurs de la police
fouillent la rivière à la recherche d'un
disque sans résultat
au vs
et on a encore aucune indication
concernant le contact
pas d'indice matériel mais un témoin un
seul
il aurait aperçu un homme à l'heure
présumé du meurtre du haut de ce pont
son témoignage permet à la police de
dresser un portrait robot
l'homme aurait une quarantaine d'années
mesurerait environ un mètre 75 et
porterait une moustache
qui est l'assassin pourquoi Lucie
a-t-elle croisé sa route seul certitude
l'homme est violent et n'a laissé que
très peu de traces derrière lui
Valter poop et le patron de la police
criminelle d'insbrook nous retournons
avec lui sur le lieu du crime
donc le cadavre de la jeune femme a été
retrouvé en contrebas
été traîné jusqu'en bas et le corps a
été laissé sur la berge
on ne sait pas comment les choses se
sont passées
alors qu'en haut aucune trace ce qui
signifie que Lucile a été surprise le
premier coup était si violent qu'elle
n'a pas pu se défendre
un meurtre d'une violence inouïe pas de
trace de lutte et au canadienne du
meurtrier retrouvé sur place
selon l'autopsie il n'y a pas
d'agression sexuelle le sac de Lucile et
son téléphone portable reste introuvable
les tentatives de géolocalisées le
téléphone n'ont rien donné crime
crapuleux ou geste d'un psychopathe les
enquêteurs n'excluent aucune piste alors
qui aurait pu en vouloir à une simple
étudiante
depuis quatre mois Lucille étudier
l'économie et le marketing dans cette
école
avec 80 autres étudiants européens elle
participait à un programme
d'échangerasmus à coufftaï en Autriche
une paisible bourgade du Tyrol au pied
des montagnes à la frontière allemande
la petite ville est célèbre pour sa
forteresse médiévale ces ruelles
traditionnelles et ses centaines
d'étudiants étrangers
Benjamin appartient à cette petite
communauté d'étudiants Erasmus à couche
time il connaît Lucile pour l'avoir
côtoyer pendant quatre mois
en fait c'était ça la salle commune
d'ordinaire très animé la cité
universitaire s'est figée depuis le soir
de l'annonce de la mort de Lucile
on s'attend pas à ce qui se passe
quelque chose comme ça un meurtre voilà
donc c'est choquant en plus il y a eu un
effet de groupe ou l'atmosphère était un
peu lourde
ou voilà quand on commence à croiser des
gens c'est vrai qu'on était tous plus ou
moins affectés donc du coup bah ça
voilà c'était c'était assez particulier
un couche time les étudiants passent
leur temps ensemble il y a les weekends
au ski et surtout les nombreuses soirées
ou Benjamin retrouvé Lucile
j'étais peut-être il nous montre une
vidéo qu'elle a posté sur les réseaux
sociaux
[Musique]
pour moi c'est comme ça qu'elle était
quand elle est en soirée quoi c'était
représentatif elle aimait voilà bouger
s'amuser
elle était hyper joyeux elle était tout
le temps contente quand on était en
boîte on avait elle avait tout de suite
envie de danser elle venait nous prendre
pour pour nous emmener danser voilà
c'était pas le genre de fille à se
mettre dans un coin à plus parler à plus
rien dire
une fille joyeuse et sympathique qui
comptait de nombreux amis Benjamin ne
lui connaissait pas de petits copains et
les policiers ont très vite conclu qu'il
n'y avait pas de suspect dans
l'entourage proche de Lucile
le blog qu'elle tenait confirme qu'elle
vivait à fond son expérience à
l'étranger
intitulé lus n'amasse pas mousse le blog
nous fait découvrir une fille tranquille
et gourmande de la vie
et prise de voyage elle aimait partager
les univers qu'elle découvrait comme ici
lors de vacances en Thaïlande
c'est donc naturellement que Lucile
racontait sur son blog ses impressions
vue d'Autriche
d'un étudiant tyrolien se résume à des
cours au pied des montagnes des peintres
à 3 euros et des weekends en station
[Musique]
Stephy et Anna sont encore bouleversées
c'était très éprouvant quand on a appris
sa mort j'ai eu beaucoup de mal à me
faire à l'idée qu'elle était morte c'est
devenu un peu plus concret quand l'école
haïté en drapeau noir ce genre
d'affaires on l'entend d'habitude à la
radio et là c'est juste à côté de nous
sur le chemin que j'emprunte tous les
jours
le maire de couche thaï et lui aussi
sous le choc
sa ville a un taux de délinquance
casinule et n'a jamais connu de crimes
de sang
depuis le drame il vient lui-même chaque
jour entretenir ce lieu de recueillement
créé spontanément par les habitants
l'émotion le submerge encore
vitesse mais j'ai vu ça le premier jour
ça m'a coupé le souffle
je ne m'attendais pas à ça c'était juste
incroyable
et donc j'aimerais que la dignité de ce
lieu soit respectée qu'il reste comme ça
intacte
pour le maire il est primordial de
retrouver rapidement la Sassin avec le
temps qui passe la psychose s'installe
doucement dans la ville pendant notre
entretien une femme vient l'interpeller
vous savez dans ma rue pour rentrer chez
moi je dois emprunter un passage très
sombre il y a bien deux petites lumières
à l'entrée mais c'est vraiment très noir
on est davantage inquiet maintenant
quand c'est mal éclairé
le soir je fais toujours un petit tour
mais je vais plus loin là-bas je viens
plus ici je n'oserai pas
car le tueur court toujours et cela
Fritz n'arrive pas à l'accepter
il connaissait bien Lucile c'est l'homme
qui lui a loué son appartement
là on est dans la cuisine
Lucile partagait l'appartement avec sa
meilleure amie venue elle aussi de Lyon
dans le cadre du programme Erasmus
souvent j'apportais le bois pour la
cheminée et même parfois je leur
préparer le feu quand elle recevait
leurs amis notamment elle faisait
souvent la fête non vous savez elle
travaillait quand même elles étudiaient
en quatre mois une relation de confiance
était installée entre les deux
étudiantes et leur propriétaire
frites étaient devenus une sorte de
paire de substitution pendant leur
séjour c'est donc naturellement que la
colocataire de Lucile s'est rendue chez
lui le lendemain matin du drame pour
signaler la disparition de son ami
à l'interphone ma femme a répondu
elle me dit que c'est la copine de
Lucile elle est en pleurs je ne
comprends rien alors je lui dis dis-lui
de monter
je lui ai demandé ce qui se passait et
c'est là qu'elle a raconté que Lucile
n'était pas rentré
j'ai répondu que ce n'était pas grave on
allait la retrouver je pensais qu'elle
avait rencontré quelqu'un elle me répond
non non elle venait d'appeler des
copines chez qui elle devait se rendre
elle n'est jamais arrivé alors là j'ai
dit c'est différent on a un problème
Fritz prend l'affaire très au sérieux et
appelle immédiatement la police
là vous voyez à 9h01 j'appelle la police
à 9h12 j'ai tenté de joindre Lucile mais
il n'y avait pas de tonalité
deux heures après l'appel de frites au
commissariat le corps de Lucie il était
retrouvé sur les berges de la rivière à
à peine 1 km de son appartement que
s'est-il passé ce soir du samedi 11
janvier sur la promenade de Lille nous
allons reconstituer l'itinéraire de
Lucile jusqu'à l'attaque dont elle a été
victime
[Musique]
aux alentours de 23h30 Lucile quitte son
domicile pour rejoindre une amie qui
habite de l'autre côté de la rivière
elle emprunte donc le pont puis longe la
promenade réservée aux piétons
à cette heure-ci c'est un lieu désert et
totalement isolé les conditions
parfaites pour une agression
à 23h45 Lucile téléphone à son ami pour
lui annoncer qu'elle sera là dans une
minute
la communication est soudainement
interrompue c'est à ce moment-là qu'elle
reçoit un premier coup très violent
visage suivi de plusieurs autres
toujours à la tête
son ami la rappelle
le téléphone sonne dans le vide il est
23h50
quelques instants plus tard un témoin
sur le pont un perçoit un homme à la
démarche suspecte c'est son témoignage
qui permettra de dresser le
portrait-robot
[Musique]
nous retrouvons Walter poupe de la
criminelle
ce matin-là il est un peu nerveux le
portrait-robot a été diffusé dans tous
les foyers de couffstein et ses environs
les centaines d'appels qui ont suivi
n'ont pour l'instant rien donné
tout le monde voudrait que ce crime soit
vite résolu et on a quand même pas mal
de gens qui donnent des infos inutiles
mais il faut les vérifier
les recherches piétines mais un
rebondissement va relancer l'enquête
ce jour-là des analyses ont confirmé aux
policiers qu'il détenaient bien l'arme
du crime
retrouver au fond de la rivière cette
lourde barbe de fer d'un kilo 7 pour 58
cm de long porte bien le sang de Lucile
a été tué
c'est un objet très résistant très dur
car c'est le levier d'un cric de camion
est que nous pouvons maintenant essayer
de trouver d'où vient cette arme
d'autres analyses sont en cours pour
tenter d'identifier l'ADN que le tueur
aurait pu laisser sur la barre
le croisement des fichiers d'auteurs de
crimes violents dans la région n'a pas
permis d'identifier un suspect
le meurtrier de Lucile est à ce jour un
parfait inconnu pourtant le policier
carte la piste du crime crapuleux
pour moi la violence des coûts on dit
beaucoup plus que le sac qu'on a pas
trouvé
par expérience je pense que les gens qui
commettent un crime avec une telle
violence en général un passé criminel
mais de cerveau
il peut y avoir plein de raisons mais
personnellement je crois qu'il a attendu
une femme
son but était de tuer une femme
qui haïssait les femmes pour l'instant
le commissaire poop n'en a pas la preuve
[Musique]
dans la chapelle ardente de l'école la
photo de Lucile souriante reste toujours
en place
peut-être de quoi apporter un peu de
soutien à des étudiants profondément
choqués inquiet aussi de savoir le tueur
en liberté